this video is brought to you by
surfsharkvpn
[Music]
what's up guys michael and his
exceedingly fancy library here
regardless of how you've been feeling
about the state of life under quarantine
or
semi-quarantine chances are we've all
had one shared experience
confusion but among that confusion there
is one consistent refrain
we just gotta figure something out until
there's a vaccine
once we get that sweet sweet attenuated
inactivated or modified virus in our
bodies
nothing will stop me from tinying in at
the olive garden but as much as i can't
wait to carbo load unlimited lukewarm
breadsticks with my fellow pasta fast
family there is one thing this whole
coveted crisis has revealed about how we
think about health
we as a society love to worship medicine
and don't worry i'm not here to hate on
all the medical advancements that save
millions of lives but there is one thing
that gets lost in the mix
public health and while this term has
become a cool new thing everyone gets to
learn about during our playgrid and
apocalypse i think there's a general
sentiment that it's just the thing you
do until medicine catches up
and to figure out why in general that's
an awful perspective
i want to talk about one of humanity's
most lethal diseases tuberculosis
welcome to this wisecrack edition on how
to stop a plague
but before we get into it i want to give
a shout out to this week's sponsor
surfsharkvpn if you're anything like me
you online shop more often than you go
to a store i mean
i can't remember the last time i went to
a mall
that means i usually am using my bank
info on various sites
it's just one reason why i find a vpn to
be invaluable
a vpn is a virtual private network which
means that once it's turned on it sends
your data through an encrypted tunnel
which protects you against malicious
cyber attacks by shielding your
information
with surfsharkvpn you can feel safe
using your computer
phone game console or any other device
to make a purchase
surfshark goes above and beyond with
their additional features like clean web
which blocks ads and malware that may
pop up while browsing
and blind search which protects your
browser from serving you targeted ads or
sponsored sites
the best part is that if you use the
link in the description right now you
can get surfsharkvpn for 85
off its normal price plus three extra
months for free
go to surfshark dot deal wisecrack or
hit the link in the description
protect yourself online and download
surfsharkvpn today
now for context tuberculosis is one
nasty ass disease
fettuccine alfredo left out in the sun
for 48 hours nasty
it is thought to have leapt from bovid's
i.e cattle or bison
approximately 17 000 years ago in its
time tb has killed as many as
2 billion people throughout history
making it as evil as like
2.2 million jonestowns it's
airborne and can cause symptoms in its
host anywhere from weeks to
decades after exposure that's right this
disease can hide in your body longer
than the simpsons has been on tv which
is to say
way too long like covet 19 symptoms
range from
asymptomatic to holy sh i'm dead in
serious cases the tb bacteria replicates
within the
lungs causing pneumonia coughs night
sweats chest pain and exhaustion
it can also catalyze such a drastic loss
of weight and strength that it appears
to consume the afflicted patient which
is why it was eventually dubbed
consumption after striking the world
with renewed
fervor in the 18th century tb surged in
europe and america at the onset of the
industrial revolution as historian frank
snowden explains in his book
epidemics in society at the time it was
known as the white
plague because of the way it drained all
the human colors from your face
the medical establishment understood
basically nothing about the disease
presuming it to be hereditary
and because many famous artists
contracted the disease often writing or
painting or composing great works while
seriously ill
tb became and i'm not joking kind of
cool
the disease itself was said to generate
intoxicating effects and drove
creativity
although his scholar matthew gandy notes
widespread opiate addiction probably
better explains this mental
effervescence
for women the disease became associated
with physical beauty
and the emaciated body pale face flush
cheek look caused by tb
became the height of fashion in some
places women would basically stop eating
or exercising wear white face powder and
blush to cosplay as consumptives that
said most victims of tuberculosis
weren't wealthy poets they were members
of the urban poor but we'll get to that
but as germ theory spread throughout the
scientific community in the late 1800s
tuberculosis stopped being a cool rich
person disease
and started being something society
wanted to declare war on
it became viewed as a disease that
punished the poor for their wretchedness
not only were people in overcrowded
slums tenements prisons
and elms houses more likely to become
infected malnourishment and pre-existing
diseases
put them at a much higher risk for
developing the life-threatening variety
of tb
in some countries a concurrent
imperialistic urge to maintain a strong
military made tuberculosis
especially in crowded barracks and on
the front lines a real
existential danger this changed mindset
helped give rise to what snowden calls
the war on tuberculosis from
approximately 1880 to 1940
which relied primarily on various public
health interventions to present the
further spread of the disease
here's where it's helpful for us to
quickly distinguish between medical
intervention and public health
a medical intervention is basically
everything you associate with going to
the doctor
getting a procedure done being
prescribed to medication etc
public health is everything outside of
that interaction
if getting a vaccine is a medical
intervention public health is
determining what vaccines people need
who to distribute them to
what new vaccines to research and
educating people on the benefits of
immunization
and interestingly enough long before tv
treatment actually worked
tv rates plummeted starting in the mid
19th century in europe and america
because of a combination of intentional
and accidental public health measures
one such strategy was the rise of the
international sanatorium movement which
advocated for
isolating tuberculosis patients at what
were essentially fascist club meds
they were first conceived of by a german
physician hermann bremmer who
experienced tuberculosis and healed in
the himalayas
he credited his recovery to fresh air
climate and rest
and so started a sanatorium to
standardize such treatment but the trend
didn't really catch on until the 1880s
with the establishment of the first
american sanatorium
little red near saranac lake in upstate
new york where patients were required to
spend eight to ten hours a day outside
soaking up the fresh air they also had
to abstain almost entirely from exercise
and eat a target of 4
000 calories a day to combat the
consumptive effects of the disease
but leaving that negative emotions like
shock or anguish stoked the illness
nurses censored patients mail to protect
them from bad news
these sorts of rules varied from
institution to institution but across
the board they made for a highly
restricted life
at the same time it also effectively
quarantined those who were contagious
which helped make a dent in the spread
of the disease
getting into little red was a highly
competitive process
and many folks who were rejected moved
to lake saranac anyway so the town
became a sort of
epicenter for tb treatment like a disney
world for the very ill
while the medical intervention here is
questionable
the strategy had the inadvertent public
health benefit of slowing further spread
of tb
typically after spending time healing at
the sanatorium patients would then
return to their urban homes
from there they would rely on
dispensaries or medical centers that
provided both
medical care and public health
strategies like offering monetary loans
or helping patients find work
importantly these dispensaries along
with a slew of ngos
also offered community hygiene education
warning against the dangers of sneezing
without covering your nose and obsessing
a little bit over the comparatively less
risky act of spitting
concurrently starting around 1840 and
admittedly a little ethically
questionable
was the segregation of the poorest
suffering from tb into workhouses and
it's widespread
movements like this that really helped
contain the disease from further spread
as scholar matthew gandy notes before
the infectivity of the disease was
understood
british workhouses admitted ever greater
numbers of consumptive patients
continuing the issue then is not the
effectiveness of
treatment but the impact of containment
on rates of infection
another social campaign about the spread
of cow tb led to the screening of herds
for the disease and the now ubiquitous
practice of pasteurizing milk
at the same time these public health
efforts intensified improvements in
nutrition
urban housing and the proliferation of
more hospitals were concurrently
fighting tb
while public health was kicking tb's ass
what new treatments were doctors
concocting
just a little thing called artificial
pneumothorax
which basically collapsed and paralyzed
the patient's lungs
which they thought would allow them to
heal like a broken bone in a cast
needless to say this did not work a
vaccine was debuted in 1921 but it was
mired in controversy because it
a was not totally effective and b
doesn't protect against all forms of tb
by the time antibiotics for tb came
around reported cases of tb had already
plummeted across europe
of course even on the public health
front there's a debate about what
stopped tb
according to some including historian
thomas mccown tv was stamped out by a
cocktail of social and economic
interventions
he points especially to improvements in
nutrition which strengthened people's
immune systems
thus making them less susceptible to its
ravages other scholars pushed back on
this interpretation
leading to a battle between
nutritionists or those who credit the
decline of tb to better human resistance
against the disease
via improved nutrition water and overall
standard of living and contagionists or
those who stress
the reduced sources of infection due to
a variety of public health interventions
contagionists believe that the decline
in tv was due to successfully
identifying and quarantining afflicted
patients
vis-a-vis sanatoriums as well as broader
public health campaigns with
dispensaries and ngos
regardless of what you believe it's
super important to note that it was some
form of public health efforts and not
medical intervention that effectively
combated this disease for
decades affecting change in everything
from workplace safety regulations to
improve sanitation
sometimes the public health part isn't
even intentional robert koch suggested
that even housing design could influence
how infectious the disease could be
you might be asking so what we've got
drugs now housing design be damned
and i'm only a few clinical trials away
from getting my bread stick out
after the antibiotic revolution began in
the 1940s
doctors believed the war on infectious
disease to be won
it was declared a dying field and med
students were discouraged from studying
it
but it's precisely because we declared
victory so confidently that we're
all let's start with something you might
have heard of
antibiotic resistance in 1943 selman
wachsman developed streptomycin
an antibiotic that when tested on a tb
patient led to full recovery
according to snowden this monotherapy or
treatment via one rock solid drug
really seemed like a miracle cure
however doctors soon realized that the
tb bacteria
was becoming resistant to the meds so
folks who underwent treatment were
becoming sick again
and what's more were now immune to the
only real treatment
so doctors developed two new medications
isoniazid in 1952
and repamphin in 1963 to supplement it
and began treating patients with all
three
thanks in large part to these
discoveries tb declined for decades
up until the mid-1980s and everyone
expected that the disease would be
eradicated by
2010. so we're in the clear right not so
fast you rascally optimist
tb eventually became resistant to all
three medications
and that's when it was about to really
hit the proverbial fan
nowadays the research laboratory is the
focus of public health
rather than social or economic efforts
as an article in the american medical
journal notes
departments of public health shed
sanitation housing reform and
even hospital care and now tuberculosis
is back
in 1985 tv cases stopped declining
over the next two years rates started
rising in the u.s and blossomed into a
full-on pandemic in eastern europe
southeast asia and sub-saharan africa
by 1993 the who declared tuberculosis a
global emergency
so much for eradication remember how
people living in poverty were
particularly at risk for tb
within the u.s those most likely to be
afflicted were traditionally
marginalized and impoverished folks such
as those who are homeless or in prison
what's more the emergence of hiv created
a brand new class of people who were
more susceptible to the bacteria
one really illustrated example can be
seen in new york city
which served as an epicenter of an
outbreak in the 80s the city had
experienced a fiscal crisis in 1975 that
led to severe budget cuts which caused
the dismantling of health
public safety and social service
infrastructures and the deterioration of
living conditions for vulnerable
populations
most ruinously the department of health
slashed budgets shuttering district
health centers chess clinics and the
city's tb hospital
as a result when the crisis re-emerged
existing hospitals were overwhelmed had
fewer staff
and fewer resources to track the
treatment of those who were sick
here we see why a medical intervention
antibiotics is not sufficient in and of
itself in stemming a disease
you also need proper public health
infrastructure to administer the
treatment track the patient's recovery
and prevent further spread
on a more global scale snowden also
credits the disease re-emergence to the
massive displacement caused by refugees
fleeing war
economic catastrophe or environmental
disasters citing refugee camps as a
perfect
incubator for spreading the illness or
just reactivating dormant cases
in sub-saharan africa the devastating
proliferation of hiv made a huge
population vulnerable
while in eastern europe the fall of
communism dismantled the medical
infrastructure
making it harder to seek treatment for
tb to this day
doctors and scientists faced an often
drug resistant disease that in the
absence of adequate public health
infrastructure
appears to show no intention of letting
up in 2017 the world health organization
estimated that there were over a half a
million cases of multi-drug resistant tb
so as you can see the battle against
tuberculosis has neither been simple
nor entirely successful in 2018
10 million folks fell ill from tb and
1.5 million
died and importantly the history of
tuberculosis shows to some extent why
waiting for medical treatments is a
gamble
don't get me wrong there's plenty of
examples where a baseline public health
measure like mass vaccination can make
us all chill out and not worry about
getting polio but the reason tb is so
interesting to us is that one
we see a disease being greatly reduced
at first without any substantial medical
intervention and two
we see the disease resurging long after
we discovered an effective medical
treatment
what this shows is how critical public
health efforts abstinent medical
intervention
really are to stop the spread of a
disease and as we face down covert 19
collectively holding our breaths that a
vaccine will manifest before the next
football season
we might get a little too used to
relying on medical advancement instead
of good
public health infrastructure and i'm not
just talking about stay the
home or the importance of looking like a
bank robber i mean disease trackers who
can stop a pandemic before it starts
researching diseases emerging in
livestock and bats affordable
distribution of vaccines and treatments
and so on
because if experts are warning us of
anything it's that we can expect
more novel diseases infecting humans
from our animal friends
and these might be way different or
worse than
covid19 a big thanks to our amazing
patrons for supporting the channel
and our podcast hit that subscribe
button and as always
thanks for watching later guys
[Applause]
[Music]
you